hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from the uh European
Team Championship on board one it is Ian
shic representing Croatia and on board
one for aeran it is tamon rajab world
number 14 and it's a really really wild
game I mentioned in the previous video
that it was the one that I started um
watching first and although it seemed
like it could have uh ended abruptly on
move 20 then it could have ended
abruptly on move 29 it actually went
into a four nights end game and that's
simply impossible possible to calculate
you could follow maybe one Knight okay
two knights three Knights very very hard
uh but you know when you have four
Knights on the board in an end game it's
best to just you know move them and see
what happens so let's see this wonderful
game even had the white pieces and he
opened with E4 as he usually does we
have Pawn to E5 Knight F3 and Knight to
F6 we have Knight captures on E5 the
classical variation of the pet of
Defense D6 and Knight back to F3 we have
Knight captures on e4 and now Pawn to D4
other moves are also possible uh my one
of my my favorites is Knight to C3 if if
you uh haven't seen it do try it you
know tends to give a very nice game
especially for Blitz D4 D5 we have
Bishop to D3 and now Bishop to F5 so
going into the classical attack we have
castles Bishop to E7 and Rook to E1 so
many many games in the data Bas nothing
new being played here we have castles
Knight B to D2 and Knight goes back to
D6 offering trade of light Square
Bishops so Knight to F1 uh Evan says
okay but if you capture I will capture
with the queen and get a free
development and that's exactly what
happens Bishop captures Queen captures
and pawn to C6 now we have Bishop to F4
and now Knight to A6 Shifting the Knight
over to C7 Pawn to H4 by Evan and Knight
to C7 we have Knight to G5 threatening
Checkmate and here just Pawn to G6 and
it's a very well-known position it has
been reached in some very very uh top
tier games for example Fabiano corana
had it against mamed yarov he played
Knight to G3 here and he won a game also
berij defeated Maxim matlakov he
continued with Knight to H2 no sorry fa
Karana also played Knight to H2 Knight
to E3 is the move that for example
Wesley so played against Yang shishov
Duda their game ended in a draw and the
move that Wesley so played is actually
the top move recommended by the engine
but even goes for Knight to G3 it has
never been played before and it is now
as of move 15 that we have a completely
new game now I'm pretty sure that even
had this uh position somewhere at home
and that he maybe even knows that Knight
E3 is a top engine move uh but that um
maybe Knight to G3 is the second engine
move but it's much much trickier so
maybe that's why he played it so okay H
we have Knight D to E8 and now Rook to
E3 going for a rook C preparing to bring
the other Rook into the game Bishop to
D6 and here even trades with Bishop
captures Knight captures and Rook a to
E1 nicely doubling up on the E55 we have
Rook to E8 offering a trade of Rooks and
now Rook to E5 even says all right let's
trade but then I get to advance this
Pawn all the way to E5 uh and here there
are a couple of moves you could consider
like maybe Knight to C4 going after the
Rook here or maybe Queen to F6 but uh
Tamar played Pawn to H6 and here an
opport an opportunity presents itself
but even does not go for it he goes back
with Knight to F3 now I'm going to show
this because it's a classical game and
it's a very very long variation some 11
moves long but white does get a winning
Advantage with Knight captures on F7 H
but it's very tricky King captures and
F7 if you capture with the Knight then
just Queen captures and G6 so King
captures to guard the pawn Now Pawn to
H5 you are threatening Queen captures on
G6 and now look at this beautiful
defensive resource Queen to G5 you
sacrifice the queen so you will get the
Rook on E1 as well Rook captures Rook
Rook captures on E1 with check King H2
and H captures on G5 Queen captures on
G6 and King to E7 uh Queen to G7 check
King to d8 and now you will start
playing with the pass Pawn so Pawn to H6
Pawn to H7 Pawn to h8 is coming and it
looks like black is uh just uh getting
destroyed but there is sort of a defense
Rook E7 Queen to G8 check King to D7 and
now Pawn to H7 trying to give up the
queen to get another queen into the game
but now Knight to
F7 uh so what you play here The Rook is
of course defended you cannot capture it
Knight to F5 goes after the rook and
this is now the winning idea Rook 8 A8
you cannot move the Rook otherwise you
lose the Knight here so you have to
defend Knight captures King captures and
now h8 Queen even the Knight captures
you will capture on G5 with check and
you have this position where it's a
queen against two knights and The Rook
uh but you are also up to Connected past
Pawn so objectively this is winning for
white uh would you win it uh very hard
to say but yeah it's a very very long
line but I really wanted to show it
since it's a classical game but even
does not go for it he goes back with
Knight to F3 and now Queen to F6 and
when I say this is the strongest line I
allow the engine to Crunch the numbers
for every move up until maybe depth 45
and then this is the line that it came
up with so I I'm guessing it is the the
strongest one uh sometimes okay maybe if
you really allow the engine to go deeper
deeper and deeper it will change the
evaluation to maybe a different line but
that's not often the case uh you know
once you reach like depth 50 it it stays
at at at a certain line so okay Pawn to
B3 uh we have Knight to E6 and now Pawn
to C4 so playing on the queen side now
uh improving the position we have Pawn
to H5 and pawn to A4 we have Rook to E7
uh and now C captures on D5 C captures
sort of offering the D5 Pawn but if even
captures the Knight to F4 will H win
material so what does even do he plays
Queen to D to he very nicely s side
steps this fork and now Rook captures on
D5 is pretty much an Unstoppable threat
there's no way to defend this Pawn you
cannot move the Knight as The Rook on E7
would hang so T forced to give up this
Pawn even captures it and now Knight to
G7 he's down a pawn but he wants to
trade and he wants to hold this being
down a pawn so even trades Rook captures
Rook captures and queen to H6 we have
Knight D to E8 and here even goes King
to H2 and this is
um I I don't have an explanation on what
king to H2 does other than maybe it's a
waiting move uh because Knight to G5 is
winning for white but but again it's
very tricky after Knight to G5 you have
to see very very deeply that after
Knight to E6 you will attack the queen
and once the queen moves you simply
trade into a winning end game as you are
up upon Pawn Rook E5 Now The Rook on E7
is undefended so you have to be careful
you have to defend the Rook Knight
captures and now after let's say Rook
captures Rook captures and F captures
you get this um Knight and pawn end game
where white is up a pawn uh which is um
well most of the times enough for a win
but objectively this is a winning end
game but he goes King to H2 and this uh
sort of loss of a Tempo um probably
there is an idea behind King to H2 maybe
just you know prepare for entering the
end game so the king is closer to the
action uh but this now allows um Tamer
to get the Knight to E6 and now the same
idea no longer applies now if you go
Knight to G5 simply Knight to f8 and
there's really no danger here H7 is
defended and that's pretty much it now
Knight three to E4 can be even met with
Rook captures on e4 and after Knight
captures there's even Queen captures on
H4 with check picking up the Knight on
e4 after at the end of this variation so
Queen to E3 instead and now we have
Queen to F4 Tamar just offers a queen
trade even goes Rook E5 and Tamer trades
Queen captures Rook captures and now
Knight to F6 uh Rook the C 3 and Rook to
D7 going after the pawn here so even
defends it and now King to G7 we have
Knight to F1 Pawn to A6 preparing Pawn
to B5 and even stops IT Pawn to A5 so
Knight to D5 and now Knight to E3 we
have Rook to D6 and now Pawn to G3 Pawn
to B5 and now captures and captures we
have Rook to B4 uh sorry uh Knight
captures on B6 Rook to B4 uh Knight to
D5 now attacking the Knight here and
Rook to B7 we have Rook to B6 now
offering a rook trade and Rook captures
Knight captures so now you have this m
Madness of an end game where you have
four Knights on the board and good luck
good luck following that uh so King to
G2 even of course starts bringing the
king into the game and F6 we have King
to F1 Pawn to G5 now we have Pawn to D5
advancing the pass D Pawn so for the
moment this is the only pass Pawn on the
board and that makes it incredibly
valuable so Pawn to C5 Knight to C5 we
have Knight to D4 defending the pawn
here and King to F7 we have King to G2
Pawn to A5 now trying to get rid of the
uh the B3 pawn and then you're going to
attend to the D5 Pawn King F3 we have
King to E8 and now King to E2 we have
Pawn to A4 B captures Knight C captures
on A4 and now Knight to B5 uh so the
Knight and pawn nicely controlling the
three squares here here so you don't
have to worry about the king approaching
Knight to C5 and now King to f three we
have King to D7 and now Knight back to
C3 the pawn is nicely defended so you do
have the luxury of actually moving the
Knight Knight to D3 and now Knight to E4
going after the F6 Pawn but Knight to E5
check King to G2 and G captures on H4 we
have G captures and Knight to G6 now
going after the H4 pawn and now even
could go for uh he actually could win
the two pawns with Knight captures King
E7 and Knight captures on H5 then comes
Knight captures on H4 four and after the
king moves let's say Knight G6 and you
are up two pawns but still Knights are
incredibly tricky bastards and it's very
very difficult to win this so even does
not rush it he plays King to G3 First
Pawn to F5 and now Knight to F6 with
check King to D6 and now he plays Knight
captures on H5 which is actually a draw
uh the the objectively winning move here
is Pawn F4 you have to stop the
advancement of the king to E5 uh whereas
your Pawn on D5 is nicely defended so
it's not like you are wasting time here
and only now after you've got this extra
Tempo you will capture here move the
Knight and start advancing the past H
Pawn or rather soon to be past H Pawn
but even captured on H5 and now comes
King to E5 and now objectively it's a
draw King H3 now comes Pawn to F4
attacking the Knight Knight to G2 and
now Knight captures on D5 we have King
to G4 and now this is a draw but you
have to play very very precise Moves In
order to draw this here's a very nice
target practice for you studi the end
game and you will be able to solve this
feel free to pause the video and find
the only move that doesn't lose the game
for Tamer uh while I give you a couple
of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on always
studying the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Knight to E3 with check that's how
you do it now it doesn't matter what
white does even if you capture material
F captures and Knight captures you
simply go Knight captures on H4 and
that's it once King captures you have
two knights and the King against a lone
King and of course you cannot Checkmate
the black king with two knights and a
king you can if your opponent helps you
but if your opponent actively tries to
avoid Checkmate then it will not be
possible H it is possible if black would
have one one pawn and then there are
some positions where you you are able to
use Tempe against the pawn and the King
to force the king into the corner and
then Checkmate him but you know with a
lone King it is simply not possible so
that's how Tamer could could have done
it but he played King to E4 and now
Evan's position is once again winning
Pawn to F3 check King to E5 and now King
to G5 and now there's no way to uh to to
to try something like that you could try
with Knight captures on H4 H but it does
not work so Knight to f8 we have Knight
G captures on F4 grabbing that pawn
Knight to E7 and now Knight to F6 we
have King to D4 and now Pawn to H5 so of
course uh there are still hopes of
sacrificing material and maybe getting a
draw if you can maybe eliminate this
Pawn then uh then this Pawn it's
possible uh but not from this position
King E3 Knight four to D5 with check
Knight captures Knight captures and now
King captures on F3 leaving even with
only the past H Pawn but it is enough
Pawn to H6 King to G3 and now Knight to
F4 we have King to F3 Knight to D5 and
now King to G3 we have Knight to F6 and
now Knight to E6 with check King to F5
and now Knight to D4 with check King to
G6 and now at rajab of trying the oldest
trick in the book Knight to E6 so if
even maybe plays Pawn to H7 you can play
Knight to f8 check and win the pawn here
which would uh make it again a draw due
to insufficient material but after this
Knight E6 move Knight to D7 was played
uh and it was in this position on move
76 that Tam rajabu resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the f8 square is defended so that means
H7 is coming uh that's all there is you
could give a check here but after King
to F5 there's nothing more to be done
Knight to D5 H7 and after Knight H E7
check King G5 uh there's no way to guard
h8 and once white gets a queen that's it
uh so yeah very very nice game by by Ian
like I said he was winning on on move 20
but uh I mean what what a line then un
move 29 but again water a line and then
he had to win this uh um four nights
endgame against Tamar jabu who is world
number 14 at a rating of 2745 after this
game he dropped to two two places so now
he's world number 16 on the live ratings
list but still I mean that's uh quite
quite an opponent to take down and uh
with minin winning on board four and
even winning on board one Croatia has
defeated
um let me just check the the margin
Croatia has defeated aeran oh with a
result 2 and a half one and a half mov
defeated burkic on board on board two so
yeah it was a draw once I was when I was
following it but um yeah seems midaro
proved to be too too too strong
uh the hold uh but yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it and that you've
learned something about uh the uh the
knights other than they are tricky
bastards you know also so that you can
maybe draw a game if even if your
opponent has two knights and you have
nothing but a king uh but yeah uh all in
all very nicely done by even so yeah
once again really hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Kevin Clark Camilo
he Schwarz Randall ingol Stefan R and
Andreas rosental for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day